[Music]
[Applause]
we haven't had a hot guy draft in a
while but when we do it gets a lot of
reaction
and we had a hot guy draft was that a
couple years ago we did boiling that may
have been like six five six years ago a
four round Hawkeye draft and uh Josh
dumel who normally listens to the show
uh he was he called in he talked to
Paulie and Paulie he wanted to know
where he got drafted with the hot guy
draft and Paulie had to say to Josh
dumel you didn't get drafted four rounds
and the reaction the reaction stunned
him but you know what he used to be a
heartthrob and it kind of let itself go
a little bit there and Josh dumel joins
us on the program the actor director and
die hard Vikings fan and of course
former quarterback at Minot State
wow what happened to you
I spiraled then you did all right are
you on a bender
I spiraled after that day that things
just went all into hell man you were
disappointed though when Paulie goes God
I I think I broke his heart when you
found out four rounds of the hot guy
draft and Josh dumel did not get
selected yeah man it's all fleeting yeah
I I came to terms with that a long time
ago actually all right well good well
you're a viking fan five or six years
ago you're a Vikings fan yeah I mean
you're used to disappointment
uh next year that's our year okay Buddy
game Spring Awakening being released
Select theaters today and uh June 2nd
Paramount Global content distribution
group okay so all the questions that
were left unanswered for the first buddy
games they're all answered in the second
one we just checked our imdbs
we didn't we didn't get credit for being
in this movie even though we do have a
cameo
is that is that why I was I was that's
what you guys were doing I thought you
were you know taking care of your
morning business or something no no what
what's the story you're a check you're
checking them the IMDb and it wasn't on
there no no no and I would would have
thought that I would have been on there
well you you will be the movie releases
today
I think that that stuff doesn't get
credited until after the movie is
released no no because they'll be like
working on a movie and who's in the
movie and then it'll say who's in the
movie
I'll take care of that Dan I promise you
because you guys were fantastic I don't
know if you saw it yet
have you seen it how would we see it
it's just coming out today it should
have been sent a link no no
yes well you're you'll be very happy you
guys you guys did a great job okay uh
kicking off this movie and uh this is
you're gonna be proud this is your
directorial debut
no I directed the first one too
this is the second buddy Games movie
okay so this is the Second directorial
Debut for uh yes yes I also directed A
Mighty Ducks episode but nobody cares
Francis Ford dumel joining us on the
dance
okay explain to us what uh buddy games
Spring Awakening is all about and uh who
is in this movie who's going to get
credit on IMDb
okay so we have uh well first of all you
are getting accredited I will make sure
that I'll call whoever I know over there
which I'd have to do a little research
uh-huh the movie is about you know the
the first one was about you know pulling
one of our buddies out from uh a dark
place and sort of leaving No Man Behind
and this one uh Dax Shepard's character
from the first one uh tragically uh
passes uh at the at the beginning of the
movie and that's partly why you guys
were in the movie to sort of report to
the world that uh up and coming actor uh
John Durfee Jr has passed
so we uh in an effort to memorialize him
uh
and against I guess the family's wishes
steal the urn from the funeral and flee
and end up uh trying to figure out what
we're gonna do with these ashes and we
decided that we're gonna go where he was
happy for he first fell in love and that
was uh spring break 1997. uh and we we
end up you know not realizing until we
get there that it is actually happening
then we thought we're just gonna go to a
beach nice peaceful Beach and and say
goodbye to our old friend and then from
there all hell breaks loose and we go
completely off the rails now you got uh
Kevin Dillon from Entourage Nick
schwarzen from uh Grandma's Boy just
that's right some of the uh some of the
stars in there
yeah dab back at all is fantastic in the
movie James Roday is is great uh it's a
really fun movie and we and we uh have
some fun with some of the
uh
some of the craziness that's going on
socially in the world right now and you
know we have fun with it we're not too
mean spirited about it but we do
definitely take some shots how often do
you show up and go let's make up a scene
let's just do something improvised
pretty much every day on these movies
whenever you have Nick Swardson on a set
you never know what's coming so uh
usually about 50 of the time it's really
good and 50 of the time there's no way
that's ever making the movie uh but you
know it's guys like that that make these
hard-hitting comedies work uh and that's
really what I wanted to do is make a
movie that
uh you know was Unapologetic and and
really funny and uh and and makes people
laugh in fact the first one that we did
we tested it and it tested higher with
women Dan than it did men which
goes to prove that they're just as
naughty as we are
but how different is this than you're on
a set of Transformers
well Transformers is a giant production
I mean the amount of equipment and crew
and sitting around is just unbelievable
we don't have the time or money to do
that we have to be really efficient
because we have to
you know and and a lot oftentimes that
forces you to be even more creative
because when you got all the money you
need it's easy to sort of waste and we
didn't have anything in it or time or
money to waste on this one and
I had a blast making this
last time you were intimidated
on a movie set
oh it's a good question
um
gosh uh
Anthony Hopkins I guess Anthony Hopkins
was pretty intimidating although he's a
sweetheart of a guy
uh that guy is pretty you know I hold
him in pretty high regard but guys get
into character and the character can be
intimidating not the person but all of a
sudden you're like damn okay
that where'd that come from in that same
movie was uh Al Pacino so I did a movie
with Al Pacino and Anthony Hopkins I
mean what could possibly go wrong the
movie turned out to be terrible
uh do you know that when do you know a
movie is going to be terrible
uh when you see the first cut usually
you're not doing it not not during that
that you go oh god well you have some
you know when when they want to shoot a
lot of Runners you know what a wonder is
when they kind of go through inner retoo
does a lot of that uh where they they
kind of the camera never stops moving
and it's just one it's one take
basically Birdman yes that would be a
Warner okay uh and
unless the director really knows what
they're doing
that can be trouble because you have
nothing to cut to and in that movie we
did a lot of winners and I was like this
could be
this could be dangerous and sure enough
the movie I mean it wasn't terrible it
just was just kind of felt flat what was
the name of it
uh misconduct misconduct
yeah
but not least not like m-i-s-s like it
wasn't somebody who was misconduct it
was just yeah just miscounter just
misconceptions misconduct uh will there
be a buddy games three
well there is a buddy against TV show
coming out uh on CBS later this fall
which is based on real it's sort of a
mix between Big Brother meets uh Amazing
Race means like Survivor yeah where
these six groups of friends like say Dad
and the danettes would compete against
me and my buddies who would compete
against a group of uh people from Philly
who would compete against people from
Washington and they all live in this
cabin together and they all compete in
these ridiculous games and uh it's it's
it's I'm really really excited for
people to see that
good well it's all buddy games all day
over here Dan no no I'm very happy for
you you got your Minot State hat on you
of course were a legendary quarterback
there for the Minot State Beavers and
you got your Vikings jersey that usually
has tears on it come post season time
are we looking this year you know how
you're looking regular season you're
like all right 10 wins 11 wins and then
postseason
ouch let me get we're good enough to get
a a pick in around
23-24 next year they're usually good
just not quite good enough although I
trust I trust O'Connell
I trust this this coaching staff I think
they're going to be good but I say that
every year so I'm just gonna keep my
mouth shut and just hope for the best
I've spoken to you after a devastating
playoff lawsuit home
that was against Seattle
yeah it was at Seattle in Minnesota yeah
they didn't have the film yet it was
outdoors and that was a the coldest
football game I've ever been a part of
it was I had a I had one of those I had
a parka I had ski goggles I had one of
those hats with the fur things
and I had my beer in my Park a pocket
and it still froze
and Walsh I think made three field goals
that game which were like 40 plus
and then he and then he Shanks like a 23
yarder to lose the game at the end and
the the the
devastation
of those fans leaving that that that old
stadium was just heartbreaking well you
know what when you had me uh FaceTime
you you called me and I could see him
like man that's a grown man and he is
devastated you were devastated
devastating
um they find a new way to break our
hearts yes they do um hey good luck with
the movie and uh we look forward to
seeing our portion of it even though we
don't get credit for it I mean I didn't
I didn't even charge you anything for
that it didn't cost you anything for us
to shoot that you're so rich it doesn't
matter you're absolutely right but we
still should have gotten compensated
here for the dentist like like ten
dollars or something for each guy well I
I appreciate you guys doing it and you
are actually very good in the movie it's
it's a fun opening
good to talk to you you too buddy all
right that's bye guys Josh dumel he's uh
actor and director Vikings fan former
Minot State quarterback hi Josh hi Josh
yeah yeah Paul yeah I looked all over I
cannot find uh hiding her hair her name
your name any name yeah yeah that's okay